Naturally, with great power
comes great responsibility.
Invoking a method that doesn't
exist is not usually a good idea.
Let me show you what I mean.
Here's an array,
similar to the last one,
but this time I swapped out
the dealer object for a string.
Now let's see what happens
when we call the method play.
No compiler errors, so far so
good, and we press run.
Uh-oh!
Of course,
we knew that was going to happen because
ns string obviously has
no method called play.
Let's take a look at
what this error says.
So, we'll scroll up to the top
of the console and it says
unrecognized selector sent to instance
and then there's a string of numbers.
You've probably seen in
an error like this before, but
you may not have realized that that
word selector comes from Objective C.
In Objective C,
selector is another name for method.
So when you see this unrecognized
selector sent to instance,
start debugging by investigating
objects with the type ID.
It's possible that the class
of the offending object
is not what you think it is at run time.
And to defend your code
against the perils of ID,
you can also use introspection.
You can ask if the object at hand
responds to the selector in question.